قريبا نودع كل الطيور بهذه الكلمات اعلن
ملك موقع تويتر ايلون ماسك عن تغيرات
جديده في المنصه قال ايلون ما
سك اي ذبح عنوان موقع تويتر اضافه الى
العنوان الحالي وضف ماسك في تغريده ان
تغيير شعار موقع تويتر الى اكس سيظهر
لاحقا اليوم
معلم فريق محمد السويسي الصحفي المتخصص في
تكنولوجيا المعلومات اهلا بك ضيفنا يعني
ما المغزى من هذه الخطوه
بالطبع هذه الخطوه تاتي في اطار برنامج
ايلون ماسك للسير بمشروعه مشروع تطبيق كل
شيء التي تحدث عنها منذ اواخر السنه
الفارطه
سرع في هذه الخطوات نظرا لان برنامج كان
ينتظر ان يمتد بين 53 سنوات لكنه فجاه قرر
ان يسرع في خطوته نحو هذه التطبيقة وقتل
علامه تويتر نهائيا ودمجها في اطار تطبيق
كبرى فيها العديد من الخاصيات هذه الخطوه
خطوه كانت منتظره لكن التسريع ياتي بعد
الزخامه الذي عشناه ايامات الفارطه مع
المنافسه بين ايلون ماسك ومالك بين الكلام
على تويتر
اي علامه جديده مع فلسفه جديده مع يعني
عالم جديد يقدمه بالنسبه لهذه الشركات
عندما تقوم بانشاء علامه جديده تسعى من
خلالها ان تتحدث عن وجه جديد
ودماء جديده وفلسفه جديده كما قلت اظن ان
بالنسبه
كان منذ سنوات يعمل على بعض الشركات اسمها
يبدا بالاكس وبالمناسبه التي تحدث عنها
ايلون ماسك ليست بالعلامه الجديده هي
علامه بدا بها مشوار منذ 1999 وهي
هذه العلامه لان
كانت بنك افتراضي تحول الى اسم باي بال في
وواحد ثم اصبحت هذه الشركه عندما باعها
ايلون ماسك مصدر ثروته التي من خلالها
اشترى تيسلا وسبيس اكس عن طريق شركه اسمها
سبيس اسمها اكس هولدي ف تعلمت اكس حاضره
حتى بالنسبه للاوراق القانونيه لشراء
تويتر منذ اواخر السنه الفارطه كانت علامه
اكس حاضره اظننا ايلون ماسك يتفائل بين
هذا الاسم والعلامه ككل يحاول من خلالها
ايلون ماسك ان يبعد نفسه عن ما يسمى
المنافسه مع مالك زوكربيرج وغيره ويجهز
نفسه لسوق جديده وخدمه جديده
يعني الى الان بعض المعطيات تخرج عن هذه
الخدمه لكن لا نعرف ما هو وجهها في
المستقبل شكرا جزيلا لك محمد السويسي
الصحفي المتخصص في تكنولوجيا المعلومات
حدثتنا من باريس